alors on vous a donné plein de rendez
vous avec des expositions des spectacles
autour de la renaissance
il y en a une ici qu'il faut absolument
visiter vous la faire découvrir tout de
suite dans un reportage
c'est cette expo qui s'appelle
renaissance 500 ans d'utopie le
reportage est signée xavier naizet et
pierre dominique le paie ses tours ses
donjons
on peut les avoir observés et visiter
souvent sans savoir que le château de
chambord est aussi une oeuvre religieuse
qui avait pour but d'impressionner le
vatican et d'imposer la france comme
fille aînée de l'église
l'exposition l'utopia l'oeuvre permet de
comprendre que l' architecture du
château s'est directement inspiré de
concept incontournable dans l'imaginaire
de l'époque tels que la jérusalem
céleste où la cité divine de
saint-augustin la vocation
ça crée de l'emploi monarchique
s'incarne dans ce donjon dans son axe
dans la coupelle central dans la
lanterne centrale devra couronne
impériale qui le coiffe et dans la fleur
de lys qui le surmonte il y à là quelque
chose qui évidemment me fait penser à
fait penser à une temple j'ai pensé à la
coupole centrale d'un temple comme celle
qui est bâti à peu près époque à saint
pierre de rome
en quelque sorte une sacralité qui est
accordée aux politiques qui est accordée
à la monarchie française
[Musique]
chambord c'est aussi un fantasme le
délire d'un roi qui a vu tellement grand
que son rêve était impossible à réaliser
jusqu'au bout on découvre ainsi des
plans des esquisses qui nous laisse
imaginer ce que chambord aurait pu être
si léonard de vinci avait vécu assez
longtemps pour accompagner sa
construction
trois pages des carnets du maître
italien appelé codex atlantique us
permettent de penser que ces études
préparatoires auraient pu être mises en
pratique ici chambord n'a pas été achevé
tel que prévu au départ alors pourquoi
pas un jour finir chambord c'est l'autre
partie de cette exposition 18 écoles
d'architecturé du monde entier ont été
invités à imaginer le chambord de demain
le projet de rond qu'on aperçoit des
rats mais rien ou qui celui d'istanbul
est vraiment un des projets
symptomatique
parmi les dix-huit puisque environ un
tiers des projets
est liée au réchauffement climatique
côté règlement du climat à la montée des
eaux et chambord devient dans beaucoup
de projets un lieu de refuge parce que
on construit des tours par exemple au
dessus des tours de chambord parce que
il ya la possibilité de construire comme
ici par exemple des niches dans l'
architecture contemporaine qu'on lui
ajoute qui permettent des niches qui
sont certes même temps bénis si je puis
dire d'accueillir des artistes en
résidence ou des réfugiés climatiques
comme c'est le cas dans le projet de
l'école boulle
sauf catastrophe au cadre de ces projets
ne devraient être réalisés mais il
raconte les obsessions d'aujourd'hui
comme chambord témoignent des obsessions
du passé voilà et vous voyez cette cette
image cette toile avec ce portrait de
françois 1er
nous sommes donc au pied de ce c'était
de cet escalier à double révolution ont
su penser par léonard de vinci
bonjour jean dotto son ville vous êtes
le directeur général du domaine national
de chambord
merci d'abord d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'avoir pris sur votre temps
parce que un petit peu chargé un champ
bord s'étendant il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passent moi c'est une belle année
habilité ses dessins sont stables
anniversaire quand même
alors je disais donc c'était on l'entend
dans le reportage et xavier d éthique
c'est le fantasme fantasme d'un roi mais
ça reste le le fantasme de toute une
époque et encore aujourd'hui c'est un
château qui pourrait encore évoluer
mais c'est aussi un message qui traverse
les siècles en fait c'est une sorte de
10 des deux cités idéales mais je crois
moi que le plus important dans ses 500
ans
si le miracle que chambord soit encore
là je chambord et traverser cinq siècles
de tubules ils vous font si la joie pour
les françaises et les français de se
dire on à chambord sadi fierté nationale
est quelque chose qui nous rassemble un
moment de l'histoire qui nous rassemble
et qu'on ouvre au monde
alors j'imagine dans votre métier vous
avez la chance donc de diriger le
domaine de chambord quand vous arrivez
le matin
vous découvrir chaque fois chamnord
différents les photographes le dise il
faudrait passer chaque matin il y a
quelque chose de nouveau une ombre une
couleur toute l'année oui les lumières
change l'atmosphère en fait c'est une
sorte de grand film historique sur bord
et ça marche toujours cinq siècles après
les fêtes surprise est intacte
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est merveilleux
et puis c'est une sorte de poésie de
tous les moments tous les jours des
odeurs des bruits des sons les oiseaux
c'est aussi ça qu'on va découvrir que le
fils de laurent charbonnier cette poésie
de la nature leur os larchitecture alors
j'imagine que bien entendu ce cet
anniversaire de la renaissance à vous a
donné des idées justes en deux mots
parce qu'on va l'évoqué tout à l'heure
rendez-vous ce week-end extraordinaire
500 cavaliers convergence au château de
chambord 500 cavaliers peut-être que le
cheval c'est le témoin méconnu des cinq
siècles de chambord facile de toujours
été là et il a vocation à être encore
plus là parce que on va ouvrir de
nouveaux itinéraires touristiques
notamment la route d'artagnan oui qui
traverse la france de villers cotterêts
à chantilly versailles chambord le val
de loire
donc on est très fiers d'être dans cette
route d'art gagnant est important aussi
pour nos territoires en val de loire
pour les gîtes etc est en fête pour tous
les acteurs du terrain mais au fond où
tous les week-ends on a des événements
tout le temps il y aura un grand
événement le 6 septembre et le voyage de
la pierre sur la loire qui est la grande
fête du territoire avec les maires des
grandes villes
très vite les étapes de la pierre sur
les sites et qui borde la loire parfait
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci pour toutes ces précisions
vous savez j'ai un problème c'est avec
lui si j'avais jamais à la retrouver
pendant dans ce journal duparay est
toujours autres pas est-ce que vous ne
seriez pas là haut par hasard lui 6 1 6
2 6 absolument donner à quelques mètres
seulement de vous à la verticale en haut
de cet escalier à double révolution et
nous allons continuer à monter les
marches pour accéder à cette tour
lanterne un privilège car beaucoup de
gens n'y ont pas accès on va rejoindre
notre invité tout de suite
bonjour lucie wozo frédéric guyot merci
de m'ouvrir la porte j'ai arrêté de
compter les marches à partir de 112
elles sont nombreuses puisque nous
sommes au coeur sur la tour la plus
haute du château freiner la tour
centrale celle qui est la plus haute à
32 mètres au dessus des terrasses c'est
une arme au coeur des terrasses au coeur
du château elle est construite elle est
construite au coeur du château
elles mêmes occurred elles mêmes à la
tête de l' axe central de ce bâtiment
qui est organisée en croix grecque c'est
à dire que l'ensemble des quatre bras et
de même distance de même longueur et au
tourne autour d'un axe central qui est
constitué par ses tours long terme qui
se termine comme on ne le voit pas par
une immense fleur de lys à son sommet
par les nôtres cette fleur de lis
saint-pierre on la voit pas parce que
elle est au dessus de nous un mais
racontez nous un petit peu qu est ce qu
elle représente la fleur de lys se situe
c'est évidemment un symbole le symbole
de la puissance royale française
elle se situe ici au dessus d'une grande
couronne qui est la couronne impériale à
laquelle françois 1er ne devait pas
avoir droit puisqu'en fait il n'a pas
été élu empereur du saint empire romain
germanique en 15/100 19 date du début de
la construction de chambord c'est son
ennemi fidèles charles quint qui a été
élu mais on constatera dans ce tout ce
château que françois 1er a continué à
utiliser cette couronne impériale qui
est la couronne fermé avec le f bien
entendu la salamandre qui est son signe
distinctif
alors ces emblèmes ces symboles on les
voit sur les arcs bouton si on lève un
petit peu les yeux il y en avait deux
solutions on les voit sur les arcs
boutants on les voit sur les différents
lanternon de cette superstructure qui
constitue la partie haute du château et
qui est comme on le voit bicolore qui
rappelle l'italie en italie c'est du
marbre blanc du marbre noir ici c'est de
l'art d'oise et de la pierre de tuffeau
pierre particulièrement facile à
sculpter
d'où la richesse des décors sculptés de
ce château c'est absolument somptueux et
faut le dire frédéric bouilleux la vue
sur le paysage et l'architecturé est
imprenable on voit et on a une vue sur
les potagers
alors je me sens il me semble que denis
gagné meyer est allé les visites et on
essaye de l'apercevoir au lucide dans
quel but vous avez un pouvoir d'ici
jeudi nous parce que nous sommes en
effet dans le potager dans le potager du
jardin de chambord avec baptiste sony
qui est le jardinier maraîchers en chef
1 ici au domaine national de chambord
alors je lance capot jeudis bio
permaculture
je dis aussi défi le cas bord et
locavore voilà c'est un peu résumé ce
qui va se passer et ce qui s'est passé
surtout des filles au départ
bonjour denis bienvenue au potager de
chambord c'était un vrai défi parce que
nous avons créé ce potager en moins de
six mois non il faut imaginer ici
en décembre il y avait des dalles béton
des bâtiments en dur qui accueillait en
fait les chevaux du spectacle équestre
le boulot bâtisse et vous avez fait ça
en six mois en effet ça en six mois avec
vraiment une histoire comme je dis que
de femmes et d'hommes parce que tous les
services du domaine national de chambord
se sont impliqués se sont investis sur
ce projet et en qui on fait que en six
mois on est capable de prouver qu à
maresché sur petites surfaces est
capable de commercialiser
il ya quinze jours nous sortions nos
premiers légumes à l'état l'âge et nous
délivre rayon nos premiers pas nissan et
c'était quoi comme comme comme légumes
alors n'avait botte de fenouil d'être à
rennes on avait des concombres des
on avait de la de l'aubergine basilic et
ça le fait quand même quand on dit bah
ce soit je vous ai fait un plat au
basilic de chambord c'est pas mal c'est
quand même pas mal
alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya de la
renaissance et un chemin croisé dans la
conception des jardins c'est ça alors le
chemin que c'est le grand courant les
deux grands courants de qu'on retrouve
une renaissance celle et les jardins à
la française ses jardins anglais ce
qu'on voit bien que ce jardin est
structuré avec des belles lignes droits
des peuples oculaires des parallèles et
puis tous les parterres qui encadrent
ces jardins ont le côté philosophique
bucolique des jardins en langue anglaise
avec différentes couleurs des reliefs
alors pour conclure on pourrait se dire
que c'est un défi d'une première étape
mais qu'il y aura d'autres étapes
il ya une deuxième grande étape parce
qu'on va s'exporter sur une parcelle de
cinq hectares et l'année prochaine avec
une ambition forte c'est de participer
au développement de l'agriculture
biologique mais surtour est génératrice
des sols et puis avec les enjeux
sociétaux actuels
on veut vraiment participer à cette
agriculture saine et délicieuse à manger
avec beaucoup de goût beaucoup de
couleurs merci bâtisse en tout cas pour
toutes ces précisions alors nous sommes
dans des anciennes écuries
et à propos des curie il ya un événement
en particulier ce week-end à chambord
500 cavaliers les 500 ans de la
naissance convergence 500 cavaliers
regardez le reportage de covin bien rosa
et de pierre dominique loupé mon cheval
pour un royaume pour ses cavaliers parti
depuis le début de la semaine de
chenonceau le royaume
ce sera chambord bien sûr un périple de
180 km à travers les bois les champs et
le village
retrouver le sens de la nature découvrir
les paysages à une hauteur de vue
différentes visiter les châteaux de la
loire le plaisir du tourisme équestre et
là sans oublier la tension que tout
cavalier doit apporter à sa monture
[Musique]
nous on a des chevaux qui sont
essentiellement croisé d'arabe donc il
supporte mieux la chaleur
par contre on en a on a aussi des mérens
et là le mérens et la petite arabes
noirs ont beaucoup plus de mal à
supporter la chaleur donc on fait plus
attention à cela des races résistantes
avec des qualités particulières
ah oui un cheval qui a pas peur qui
réussit à faire confiance à son cavalier
même si c'est pas le cavalier qui me
qu'ils montrent souvent donc c'est un
cheval qui peut s'adapter aussi aux
conditions nouvelles
mais l'essentiel est sans doute dans la
communion avec son passeur d'émotions
qu'est le cheval
[Musique]
tous attendent avec impatience de voir
enfin chambord
les 500 ans et voilà j'ai un peu peur
rien que d'y arriver j'ai un petit peu
peur la densité de chevaux le tout
l'animation ça va être un chambord
totalement différent ce week end ils
revêtiront les habits d'époque pour
entrer dans la peau des gentilhommes et
des gens peu d'âme du xvième siècle et
qui de plus approprié pour nous en
parler que l'organisateur de l'événement
bonsoir pascal de boot il faut savoir
que l'équitation française est née à la
renaissance et donc tout un symbole
exactement puisque si on parle de
renaissance nous on peut parler de
naissance puisqu'à cette époque là on
passe d'une équitation utilitaire
puisqu'on aller à cheval pour pour le
transport à une excitation qui devient
une équitation savantes et à la
renaissance les grands mâts d'équitation
qui ont été inventés l'équitation sa
vente en italie arrive en france
elle deviendra ensuite l'équitation de
tradition française monsieur de boots
est conçu comme un dialogue entre le
passé et le futur entre l'équitation
extérieur et l'équitation de tradition
c'est cela exactement ce que vous en
prie suivi on y va on se balade qui a
reprend bien sûr ce qui a été fait
depuis la naissance du château puisqu'on
aura 500 cavaliers 500 chevaux dimanche
qui vont flâner dans le domaine pourra
dans des costumes entre 15 119 et 1919
on estime qu'à cette époque là on va
commencer à venir en voiture les moins à
cheval
on peut parler d'un riche héritage
équestre tout même exactement
l'équitation c'est quelque chose qui
était très riche et qui est très riche
en france et particulièrement dans le
val de loire
donc on le met en avant avec une
flânerie et caisses où les gens vont
déambuler vous allez voir des choses des
choses du passé les choses nouvelles
on va tourner autour de l'art des
sculptures on aura des peintures j'ai
une artiste il ya pas de 500 chevaux
dans la journée et on va avoir des
choses un peu plus technique on va voir
des bourrelier des maréchaux ferrants on
va avoir des démonstrations multiples et
variées il ya une quinzaine de paul on
va voir des poulains voir devant le
château
vous allez avoir des poulains avec leurs
mamans qui viennent de naître dans le
val de loire
donc on a des grands noirs du berry des
les percherons
il ya plein de choses qui vont se passer
ce dimanche 30 janvier il
au château de chambord vous nous mettez
l'eau à la bouche j'imagine que de
nombreux de nombreux cavaliers ont voulu
rejoindre à cet événement et oui le
compteur s'est arrêté à 5 cents à un
moment donné il y avait 500 cavaliers où
on m'avait dit que la jauge était à 500
il est évident qu'au bout de ces
déviants oui on a arrêté la jauge à un
moment donné on a refusé mais bon on sai
t on n'a pas été on avait un peu peur
d'être dans la minute qui aurait été un
peu embêtant mais non sa sas permis
celui qui a voulu il a pu quand même
alors ce sens moral est un lieu qui a
toujours sublime et et unis les chevaux
mais pas seulement
tous les animaux sont mis en valeur et
d'ailleurs vous êtes accompagné denis
d'un invité qui peut en témoigner il me
semble ah oui oui absolument lui si
c'est laurent charbonnier le réalisateur
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bien sûr c'est un réalisateur animalier
mais pas que mais pas que on va parler
de son film chambord et qu'on est bien
placé ici pour en parler
chambord qui sentira le il se taira le
19 septembre 19 septembre avant de
retrouver l'art en charbonnier je vous
propose de regarder le reportage donc à
réaliser autour de laurent charbonnier
de ces animaux qui au fil maca et xavier
naizet pour les besoins de son long
métrage laurent charbonnier a parcouru
de jour comme de nuit et par tous les
temps
des 5400 hectares de ce domaine le
cinéaste animalier avait une mission
délicate raconter les 500 ans de chant
bas j'ai passé beaucoup beaucoup de
matinée mais des vraiment le tout petits
jours pour voir les premiers rayons de
lumière avec la brume et animaux qui
traverse les sangliers et les cerfs etc
on a des séquences de nature avec les
martins pêcheurs qui s'accouplent dans
le fossé de l'étang des bons hommes
on a évidemment le brame du cerf il ya
également les sangliers pendant l'hiver
enfin bon voilà donc toutes les saisons
ont été couvertes et lycées ce qui est
intéressant à ce qui est assez jolie
dans notre film enfin c'est ce mélange
un petit peu de la pierre et de la et de
la forêt de
de la nature de ce lieu chargé
d'histoires et de personnages hauts en
couleur le cinéaste animalier a su
apporter un supplément d'âme
en conjuguant habilement la faune et la
flore c'est une première de ne pouvoir
évoquer un château et de pouvoir filmer
comme ça librement drain monument aussi
magnifique un an de tournage 300
ardimages et au final un long métrage
d'une heure et vingt minutes
c'est un maire un film dont on mélange
le château l'histoire la nature la forêt
et puis avec des séquences d'animation
qui sont très jolis qui a 13 c'est comme
dans le film où on veut quand on voit
françois 1er et charles quint qui arrive
à chambord il arrive en images
d'animation
quand on voit le 14 qui assistent aux
bourgeois gentilhomme c'est également
une séquence animée et donc c'est ce
mélange un petit peu des détroits gens
on va dire qu'elle est plutôt original
et sympathique 500 ans de chambre le
film de laurent charbonnier sortie en
salles le 25 septembre
parallèlement à ce long métrage un livre
est également attendu il sera
abondamment illustré des photos du
tournage voilà pour votre film
chambord c'est un titre ronfort est à la
fois dont on comprend que vous avez une
totale renaissance de votre regard
laurent charbonnier sur chambord vous
découvrez on en parlait tout à l'heure
vous découvrez chambord à chaque fois
que vous venez
oui je découvre au jambon chaque fois
que je viens c'est vrai que depuis une
trentaine d'années une quarantaine
d'années je suis pas mal de fois on a
fait un film sur le cers on à fait
différents films pour la télévision mais
là c'est vraiment un film pour le cinéma
mais on a soigné vraiment l'image le son
la musique le commentaire bien
évidemment pour le cinéma
cécile de france et sa voix nous
transporte dans l'incantation bord
évidemment et puis le son de philippe
barbeau martin taudis school la musique
de d'anne-sophie vietnamienne et l amf à
toute l'équipe a vraiment beaucoup
travaillé matile de nouveau pour le
montage
enfin jérôme qui m'assiste et donc du
coup c'est devenu un film que je voulais
faire depuis longtemps
et quand jean d'haussonville m'a dit
j'aimerais bien un jour que tu fasses le
film que tu as envie de faire c'était
vraiment l'occasion de le faire pour lui
et pour l'anniversaire way pour ainsi d
un spa réalisateur 16 atteint un grand
moment de savoir prendre pouvoir le
faire je disais talent renaissance de ce
château de la nature de de la flore de
la faune séquelles constant constamment
en mouvement c'est ça alors c'est
constamment en mouvement
c'est vrai que j'ai plus l'habitude de
filmer la faune la flore la nature etc
mais comme j'ai une formation de
photographe vous mettez dans la
cathédrale de chartres oui évidemment
ici je me suis beaucoup amusé évidemment
avec les lumières les ombres le décor
les lignes la structure de la pierre et
c est donc ce film qui est un mélange en
fait de l'image de pierre de nature de
la forêt c'est vraiment chambord le
château mais chambord aussi la forêt
bien évidemment et puis et nous avons
également eu l'idée de s'associer des
images d'animation des séquences
d'animation est con quand on voit
charles quint et françois 1er qui arriva
chambaud il arrive en images d'animation
bon et donc voilà liane pas mal de ses
comptes donc c'est un mélange assez
originale entre très bien la nature la
forêt et le gers il c'est un bonheur de
vous entendre parler un réalisateur
comme est un cinéaste comme laurent
charbonnier léonard de vinci il en a
fait des trucs qu'il en a pensé lui
sicié intéressés voici la vie ce prêt
est rien
si ce randonneur blessé peut être
secourus sur une pente à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
c'est grâce à leonard raccourci certes
mais de vinci est tout de même à
l'origine du premier hélicoptère de
l'histoire aussi appelé la vis aérien
entre 14 187 des 14 190 l'ingénieur veut
vérifier que l'air est un fluide sur
lequel on peut appuyer et s'appuyer pour
remonter en vol il créé une spirale
rigide fixer un mât central posée sur un
socle avec une série de réunions en bois
elles servent de support à une aile en
l'a recouverte damidot de manière à
réduire sa porosité
le principe est simple la vie s'est
propulsée par un ressort et les hommes
doivent la faire tourner dans le sens
des aiguilles d'une montre
une fois la tension maximale atteinte le
resort dispose de suffisamment d'énergie
pour faire tourner la vis dans le sens
inverse
elle est alors libéré de sa base et
prend son nom
inconvénient de l'époque
les muscles d'un homme ou d'un animal
pouvait alimenter cette machine en
énergie évidemment trop faible pour
prendre son envol
il faudra attendre l'arrivée des moteurs
pour que son invention prenne tout son
sens
c'est aujourd'hui un moyen de locomotion
indispensable bravo léonard